sollten dumme menschen sterben er dachte
doch nicht dass es klick welt oder
[Musik]
vor kurzem habe ich ein video zur tat
potash hochgeladen und in den
kommentaren tauchen immer wieder zwei
begriffe auf nämlich darwinismus und
natürliche selektion brüder starben
schwache menschen in dem sie von
säbelzahntiger gefressen wurden heute
sterben dumme jugendliche in dem sie
waschmittel prozessen natürliche
selektion muss man denn dumme menschen
schützen indem man ihnen so bleibt
sicher und er ist kein waschmittel oder
sollte man einfach den darwinismus
verhalten lassen war die geduld ich
wünsche mir dass der darwinismus einfach
volle apple zu auf diese idee jedoch auf
die spitze getrieben bei den sogenannten
darwin awards die darwin awards sind
satirische awards sie zeichnet menschen
aus die sich versehentlich selbst töten
tödlich verunfallten oder selbst
unfruchtbar machen und ein besonderes
maß an dummheit zeigen weiter steht der
gedanke dass ein lebens und tüchtiges
individuum seiner art einen gefallen tut
wenn es die verbreitung des eigenen
erbguts verhindert sprich je mehr dumme
menschen sterben desto weniger dummes
erbgut und desto schlauer die künftigen
generationen der menschlichen spezies
falls sie die darwin awards noch nicht
kennt könnt ihr euch selbst ein bild
davon machen link in der beschreibung
ich persönlich finde die darwin awards
so ziemlich genau 0% witzig das grausame
an einem tod ist ja nicht nur der tod an
sich sondern vor allem auch das leid der
hinterbliebenen also ich finde die
darwin awards einfach nur geschmacklos
aber das ist meine eigene meinung die
auch gar nichts zur sache tut denn über
humor kann man sich ja bekanntlich nicht
streiten
zumindest sollte man das nicht aber wenn
es schon schwarzer humor ist dann würde
ich doch wenigstens erwarten dass die
wissenschaft dahinter stimmt und das tut
sie leider vorne und hinten nicht umso
mehr irritiert es mich dass die darwin
awards vor allem in gebildeten
akademischen kreisen beliebt sind
immerhin gut der witzige auf der
wissenschaftlichen basis der
evolutionstheorie was ja ein gewisses
maß an bildung voraussetzt die gründerin
der darwin awards ist selbst
molekularbiologin und berkeley
absolventen
deswegen möchte ich heute auch gar nicht
auf ethischer ebene rumheulen warum ich
die trotz geschmacklos finde sondern das
ganze rein wissenschaftlich angehen hier
also wir gründe warum die darwin awards
wissenschaft ich habe bullshit sind nur
eins dass dummheit gehen ist dummheit
überhaupt genetisch bedingt oder nichts
also nach über 100 jahren forschung weiß
man heute eigentlich nur dass
intelligenz durchaus eine starke
genetische komponente hat aber auch dass
umwelteinflüsse eine rolle spielt kurz
gesagt auf die frage ob intelligenz
genetisch bedingt ist gibt es bis heute
noch keine eindeutigen und einfachen
antworten falls ihr euch für das thema
interessiert verlinke ich euch ein paar
artikel in der video beschreibung aber
trotzdem kann man hier logisch
argumentieren möglichkeit dummheit ist
nicht genetisch bedingt in diesem fall
macht natürlich das ganze konzept der
darwin awards können sind möglichkeit b
dummheit ist genetisch bedingt ja nur
dann würde man natürlich auch dumm
geboren werden genauso wie man mit einer
gewissen hautfarbe geboren wird und das
wäre ähnlich sinnlos sich über etwas
lustig zu machen wofür ein mensch gar
nichts kam mit nummer zwei der tod
entfernt ich nicht aus dem genpool ich
mache zu viele er kurz heute wenn ich
jetzt sterbe steht mit mir nicht einfach
alle meine gene zum beispiel habe ich
auch noch ein bruder der ein
potenzielles dummheit gehen weiter
verkehren können außerdem beruht das
ganze auf einem ziemlich weit
verbreiteten irrtum der mit diesem
survival of the fittest schon wieder
zweifel auf der fitness zusammenhängt
zwei der evolution und der natürlichen
selektion geht es gar nicht primär ums
überleben sondern vielmehr um
reproduktion also um den fortbestand der
art und genau genommen ist die reine
reproduktion auch nicht allein
ausschlaggebend wenn wir zum beispiel
ein rudeltier nehmen dass seine rudel
effektiv schützt sich selbst aber gar
nicht fortpflanzen
dann hat das trotzdem für die ganze art
einen evolutionären vorteil aber es
macht definitiv keinen sinn einen
erwachsenen mann der zwei kinder hat und
auf saudumme art und weise stirbt mit
einem darwin award auszuzeichnen weil er
sie schon längst fortgepflanzt hat er
hat sich damit ein bisschen zu spät aus
dem genpool entfernt
und interessanterweise wird der darwin
award nicht an kinder und jugendliche
verliehen gibt es dafür irgendeinen
wissenschaftlichen grund einer der mir
ein leuchten würde denn es würde sehr
viel sinn machen den darwin award an
kinder und jugendliche zu verleihen weil
die sich in der regel noch nicht
fortgepflanzt haben oder es ist eine
ethische entscheidung weil keine witze
über verstorbene kinder und jugendliche
macht das geht so weit wie sie über
verstorbene erwachsene klar aber wird es
über kinder und jugendliche sind doch
keine monster es heißt das der grund
sein sollte finde ich das nicht
besonders weit gedacht denn unter den
hinterbliebenen dieser verstorbene
menschen über die man sich jetzt im
internet lustig macht befinden sich
sicherlich auch kinder und jugendliche
die schon genug unter dem tod an sich
leiden und jetzt auch noch darunter
leiden müssen dass sich fremde menschen
nicht nur über den tod sondern auch noch
über die dummheit lustig machen also ich
wollte nicht moralisch werden bleiben
wir bei der wissenschaft immer drei
evolution verbessert nicht den genpool
der begriff natürliche selektion klingt
auch noch eine aktive selektion als
würde die evolution einen plan verfolgen
eine systematisch verbessern
die wahrheit ist die evolution hat
keinen aktiven plan wie irgendein gott
sondern ist völlig rennt es geht hier
nicht um systematische verbesserung es
geht nicht darum dass spezies immer
stärker größer schneller oder
intelligenter werden sonst gäbe es auch
nicht die artenvielfalt die wir auf
diesem planeten beobachten können
spezies verbessern sich nicht sie
passten sich nun immer besser an ihre
umwelt und die umwelt ist gleichzeitig
natürlich auch ein teil der evolution
und entwickelt sich und passt sich
nehmen wir als beispiel den kino dem
nationalvogel neuseelands vergleicht man
den kiwis mit anderen vögeln dieses
planeten bekommt man leicht den eindruck
dass der kiwi anderen vögeln objektiv
unterlegen ist kann nicht fliegen kann
ich super schnell laufen er ist nicht
groß genug um sich gegen raubtiere zu
verteidigen und nicht klein genug um
sich leicht zu verstecken und
tatsächlich wären die kiwis heute schon
längst ausgestorben seit die menschen
mario bros und ähnliches nach neuseeland
eingeschleppt haben babys sind heute nur
noch über
lebensfähig dank großer bemühungen
vieler naturschützer und trotzdem hat
die evolution in neuseeland den kiwis
genauso hervorgebracht dass freunde der
sonne ist ein survivor und einer of the
fittest der kiwi war einfach perfekt an
seine umgebung angepasst ist der mensch
kam und ein paar male ausgesetzt genauso
ist der homo sapiens tieren in vielen
dingen unterlegen zum beispiel würde
einen menschen baby alleine sofort
sterben während schildkröten babys
schlüpfen ins meer laufen und einfach
anfangen zu schwimmen objektiv und
wissenschaftlich korrekt gesehen gibt es
keine guten und schlechten oder bessere
gene
man kann nur gut oder schlecht an seine
umgebung angepasst sei es ist nicht nur
wissenschaftlich falsch sondern kann
auch ethisch grenzwertig gefährlich
werden wenn man evolutionstechnisch
hierarchisch denkt in gut und schlecht
weil im extremfall kommen dann so
auswüchse wie die idee von der
herrenrasse dabei raus und ok jetzt bin
ich ethisch sehr weit abgeschweift
zurück zur wissenschaft nummer hier
intelligenz ist keine reproduktions
vorteil nehmen wir an intelligenz ist
genetisch bedingt
dann gibt es doch bei aller liebe einige
andere genetisch bedingte eigenschaften
die bei der fortpflanzung von forscher
sind sind wir doch mal ehrlich ohnehin
streiten sich experten darüber ob die
evolution derzeit bei menschen überhaupt
noch so stattfindet oder wie die
evolution in modernen zeiten zu bewerten
ist dass kiwi beispiel ist nur ein
beispiel von vielen dafür wie der mensch
seine umgebung so rasant verändert viel
schneller als die evolution nachziehen
kann ich meine intelligenz ist für
menschen und in ihrer umgebung
sicherlich ein genereller vorteil und
phänomene wie der flynn effekt zeigen
dass sich menschen auch hier durchaus an
ihre umgebung anpassen heißt nicht was
der flynn effekt ist sehr interessant
video in der infobox und intelligenz
korreliert heutzutage mit sachen wie
einkommen oder lebensstandard aber
pflanzen sich reiche akademiker mehr
fort er nicht würde ich sagen
mir fällt jetzt erst auf das man aus
genau diesem grund argumentieren könnte
dass man die darwin awards braucht die
menschheit für dunkt intelligenz ist
kein evolutionärer vorteil mehr
deswegen ist auch ein grund zum feiern
wenn sich ein dummer mensch umbringen
das kann man so sehen aber dann darf man
das ganze natürlich nicht darwin awards
nennen denn mit david hat dass da nichts
mehr zu tun sondern muss es dann wir
feiern den tod der menschen aus rein
ethischen gründen ohne wissenschaftliche
basis awards nennen
und jetzt mal im ernst so der meniskus
kommentare und selbst die darwin award
an sich sind ein witz die sind als witz
gedacht
ich finds nicht witzig aber das tut
tatsächlich nichts zur sache
doch big bang theory nicht witzig es
geht mir wirklich nicht um irgendeine
humor debatte und gerade unter einem
video über die typo challenge wo er zum
glück noch keiner gestorben ist finde
ich das auch weniger problematisch mir
geht es darum dass deutsche aufgeklärt
sind und wenn sie so wie zu machen wieso
funktioniert evolution nun mal möchte
ich dass sie wenigstens wissen dass
evolution sonova nicht funktioniert und
egal wie intelligent sitzt tatsächlich
genetisch bedingtes dummheit hat am ende
sehr viel mit bildung zu tun deswegen
teilt dieses video wenn ihr dieses video
teilt dann macht das die menschheit auch
ein bisschen schlauer
ich bin schadens treibt sicher freunde
der sonne wir sehen uns in der endphase
was ich auch noch dachte bei der teilt
talent so dumm die auch ist oder war als
ich 12 13 jahre alt war habe ich viele
sehr dumme sachen gemacht ich bin in der
kleinstadt aufgewachsen und bei uns auf
dem dorf haben viele mit 13 angefangen
zu saufen und wenn mal alkoholabbau in
zügen nicht goutiert wäre hätte ich
ziemlich wahrscheinlich auch mitgemacht
und das ist im zweifel noch gefährlicher
als ein waschmittel vor zuerst deswegen
also ganz ehrlich so unter uns was habt
ihr früher so dummes gemacht und habt
ihr schon mal durch dummheit euer leben
gefährdet schreibe es in die kommentare
und ich werde euch dafür nicht
verurteilen